اذا من الشوارع الى الشواهد تظاهرات هو
الايرانيين وان اختلف نمطها طابعها واحد
ولا يتغير وان حاول النظام طمسها او ان
يمحي تفاصيلها ومعالمها على عتبه المئه
يوم تبقى ميزه الاصرار على اسقاط النظام
الموت لخامنئي مطلب مرتفع السقف لا تهداته
ويستوجب على الاقل الاصلاحات غير ان هذه
الكلمه صعبه في القاموس الايراني خلينا
يعرف ان الثوره انتصرت في اللحظه التي
شعرك قادتها بانشاء يفكر بتقديم اصلاحات
وهل يخاطر المرشد ومؤسسات النظامه ورجاله
المتشددون قبل الخضوع للشارع وتغيير
سلوكهام
الاجابه بلا انتظار او مراجعه
لسلوك القمع والقتل الاعتقال والاعدامات
في ثلاثه اشهر ومن سطح التصريحات
الدبلوماسيه حسين امير عبد اللهن راس
الخارجيه الايرانيه نظام ايران الديمقراطي
وكغيره من الانظمه الديمقراطيه معرضا
للصعود والهبوط والفتيات الايرانيات
الشابات مرتزقه دسهن الاعداء لخلع اغطيه
رؤوسهم في شوارع البلاد والكلام هنا لاحمد
عالم الهدى ممثل الخامنائي في مدينه مشهد
بعيده عن الواقع وربما هي اقرب الى
السخريه بالنسبه للراي العام الذي باست
تشكله طاقه الرفض والمجابهه التحدي
والاصرار ولكن للمفارقه في جوهر هذه
التصريحات الامر جدي
ومصيريا بالنسبه لنظام ترتبط باستمراريته
بشكل مباشر بالايديولوجيا
تواجه اليوم اختبار صعبا يتمثل في رفض رمز
الثوره وازاحه الرمز سيؤدي الى تداعي
الايديولوجيا تماما كما يتداعل بناء عند
ازاحه حجر الزاويه
الاعداء هم السبب ومن جميع انحاء العالم
بحسب حسين سلامي قائد الحرس الثوري من قبل
ومن بعده خامنئي رئيسي عبد الله وزير
الداخليه احمد وحيد وغيرهم باختصار
الروايه المعلمه في اطار تخوين المحتجين
والتدخل الخارجي لكن هناك من خرج عن اطار
المالوف الى ما وراءيات
شوفو مين مفتاح الجنه
مكالمه
اداريه كشفار حتى النظمات
[موسيقى]